die alte baraner sind
von einem anderen Planeten und die waren
hier ganz normal mit einem Diplomaten
[Musik]
herzlich Willkommen zu alternative
Fakten seit Corona ja wieder total in
Mode Hilfe Bill Gates will uns alle
zwangsimpfen und schippen da haben wir
von den öffentlich-rechtlichen auch
einen aufklärungsauftrag deshalb möchte
ich hier noch einmal ganz deutlich sagen
nein wir beide Lutz van der Horst und
Carsten van rissen sind nicht von Bill
Gates gechipt worden genau wir sind von
Oli welke geschippt worden und seitdem
kann er uns halt steuern und wir müssen
überall hin auch gegen unseren Willen
oder meint ihr ich war 2017 freiwillig
bei der Impfgegner Demo nein
Frau Dr lingenauer sie sind Sprecherin
des kinderärzteverbands warum sollte man
Kinder impfen erklären Sie es mir doch
mal so als welchen Idiot oder sagen wir
ein Impfgegner
Kinder sollte man impfen damit sie gut
geschützt sind vor Erkrankungen die
gefährlich werden könnten für sie und
die man mit durch eine Impfung
verhindern kann aber kann man ihnen
trauen sie haben Schulmedizin studiert
ja man kann uns trauen
verabreicht ihnen nicht das Gift wofür
oder wogegen wird hier heute
demonstriert wir sind hier
zusammengekommen weil wir gegen die
drohende Zwangsimpfung produzieren
möchten es gibt keine einzige
wissenschaftliche Studie die das
wirklich klar belegt dass impfen wirksam
und vernünftig ist aber die
Kinderlähmung zum Beispiel wurde ja
ausgerottet nach der Schluckimpfung in
den 60ern
ja und wo ist der
zusammen
[Musik]
ja das macht sein viele Leute aus
Krisengebieten lassen ja ihre Kinder
nicht impfen zum Beispiel Syrien oder
Prenzlauer Berg
ja wahrscheinlich eher vom Prenzlauer
Berg die Eltern wollen alles
mitentscheiden und
wollen sich viel Hintergrundwissen
aneignen und wenn sie dann durchs
Internet stöbern dann erkennen haben sie
natürlich jede Menge von Informationen
und das wird dann schwierig das zu
filtern es ist wichtig meines Erachtens
dass Kinder Kinderkrankheiten
durchmachen um Ihr Immunsystem zu
stärken und mein Kind ist auch nicht
geimpft das 20 Jahre alt das hatte gar
nichts finde ich schade also ich hätte
gerne gehabt dass er was kriegt aber er
hat nun mal nichts gekriegt aber sie
sind auch eine grausame Mutter oder
warum in welche im freie Zeit würden
sich am liebsten zurückversetzen lassen
ins frühe Mittelalter mit der Pest oder
eher in später Mittelalter mit der Cola
war ja ich bin in der DDR aufgewachsen
wenn er das unterschreibt dann lasse ich
mich auch impfen aber das ist alles
aufgeführt und dieses Risiko wird kein
Arzt eingehen was steht denn da drauf
auf dem Schreiben da steht alles drauf
die ganzen die ganzen riesigen stehen da
drauf diese Schreiben habe ich aus dem
Internet ja das wird auch zur Verfügung
gestellt das hat Hand und Fuß also
Internet ist auch eine seriöse Sache
denke ich auf jeden Fall
den Freiheit ich gebe Ihnen ein Beispiel
jemand hat ein Haus und komm Hagel und
da durch Hagel sind paar Dachziegel
Stein zerstört und das ist das mit
dieser Antikörper haben sich gebildet
also 80er Steine sind zerstört und sagt
sind sie Dachdecker nee das sind nur
Beispiele fahren wir
industrieargumentieren aber sie sind
Arzt nein 80 ich sage wie die
funktionieren ja sie vergiften eure
Kinder machen im Moment noch Moneten
bitte bitte impft sie nicht
bräuchte ihnen nicht das jetzt
ich weiß auch von einem der höchsten
steuerinspektoren von Hamburg
dass er mal
irgendwo war auf dem Land und da kam
ganz viele missgebildete Kinder also die
offensichtlichen Schaden hatten wo war
das ich weiß nicht wo das war wann war
das das war jetzt vor einigen Jahren
vielleicht vor 10-15 Jahren und dann hat
er damals einen der Begleitpersonen
gefragt was sind das für Kinder ja das
sind lauter Impfschäden die wir hier
vor der Gesellschaft verstecken so hat
es mir erzählt das heißt zusammenfassend
kann man sagen sie haben gar keine Angst
auch vor Viren
danke ich Ihnen für das Interview
erstmal vielen Dank
ja gut aber hoffentlich kommt sie mit
Nein zurecht mein Lieber
so ich will auch mal eine
Verschwörungstheorie raushauen kommt das
Coronavirus vielleicht gar nicht aus
Wuhan sondern hat sich erstmals
verbreitet als du auf deine Hand
gehustet hast und damit der armen Frau
Hallo gesagt hast immerhin haben noch
ein paar Leute mit mir geredet sonst
hört man ja immer nur Lügenpresse um mit
dem sogenannten Staatsfunk wollen die
dann alle gar nicht reden ne das ist mir
auch mal durch Zufall aufgefallen also
weißt du ich bin ja ein alter weißer
Mann und ich habe so meine Gewohnheiten
ich gehe zum Beispiel jeden Montagabend
gerne spazieren und du trägst dann auch
jedes mal das gleiche Outfit ne ist ja
Tradition genau montags zum Beispiel
trage ich eine russenmütze ja und eine
gelbe Sonnenbrille und ein Mikrofon von
Russia Today
das mache ich schon seit den 80ern aber
wann das genau angefangen hat kann ich
dir gar nicht sagen und dann 2014 bin
ich bei einem montagsspaziergang rein
zufällig in eine pegida-demo in
Düsseldorf geraten und das irgendeinem
Grund haben dich die Demonstranten dann
für ein Reporter von Russia Today
gehalten dabei war ich einfach nur
spazieren absolut warum macht die
Mainstream perese hier keine Berichte
weil
die deutsche Presse nicht überwiegend
heißt das Mainstream und hat bestimmte
politische
Vorbehalte gegen alles was vermeintlich
rechts ist wir haben gefunden und eine
schimpfen lassen müssen von ihre drinnen
gesagt Nazis wir sind Nazis sie sind
Nazis nein das denke ich nicht ich denke
Russia Today ist objektiv unsere Presse
das sind die Verräter sie sind ein
schönes gegen nicht für unseren
gleichgeschalteten Medien zu unserem
Startpunkt der uns hier alle manipuliert
wir sind das Volk da sind ganz viel
Nazis ist das wahr stimmt wir sind keine
Nazis die allermeisten die sich aus der
Mitte der Gesellschaft ich bin
afd-mitglied der Alternative für
Deutschland auch kein Hooligan ja oder
ich weder Hooligan noch
rechtsradikal wir stehen hier auch für
die Leute und deren Kinder ja die
irgendwann meinen Frieden groß werden
sollen in Frieden groß werden sollen
warum sind Sie heute hier können Sie das
noch mal sagen aus dem gleichen Grunde
wie ihr ja ich habe Angst davor dass sie
Salafisten die Isis hier von drüben hier
rüberkommt und uns den Kopf abschneiden
will ja unseren Kindern und nicht Islam
Gläubige nächsten nicht mehr dass sie
herkommen dann machen
die deutschen Renten sind nicht mehr
gesichert
wie man dann daher gehen kann und jeden
Ausländer reinnimmt auch die
Wirtschaftsflüchtlinge nicht nur die
Kriegsflüchtlinge der Islam machte sagen
wir Punkt sagen wir auf Punkt macht der
macht der Islam Renten kaputt
in der Masse wie er sich anbietet und
wie er kommt und wir noch kommen wird in
den kommenden Jahren macht natürlich der
Islam logischerweise
volkswirtschaftliche Rechnung die Rente
kaputt keine Frage wenn jemand dir
kriminell hört Auto klaut oder jemand
Körperverletzung macht nehmen raus haben
Sie schon mal persönlich ein Schicksal
erlebt vom Serben Auto geklaut worden
weil er selber ein Islamist nein ich
mache keinen Unterschied zwischen den
deutschen Politikern für mich sind hier
alle gleich zur verurteilen würden Sie
gerne unser Kanzler sein
grundsätzlich ja
ein Homosexueller oder eine vertikaler
islamistin der radikale ist ja nicht
der ist schlimmer ja der ist hundertmal
schlimmer als ganzer Stadion voll
Homosexuellen
damit gebe ich mit diesem sehr schönen
Worten gebe ich zurück nach Moskau
wow ich wusste gar nicht dass du so gut
einen schlechten russischen Akzent
nachmachen kannst nicht so schwer wenn
du einmal hast Übung okay du kannst
jetzt ruhig damit aufhören womit ich
aufhören soll
was was du meinst okay ist das jetzt so
ein Akzent oder hast du einfach zu viel
Chemtrails eingeatmet was ich dieses
camp-trail ich kenne nur
Krim Trail
dann aufpassen jetzt gut genau aufpassen
ja
können Sie mir erklären was Chemtrails
sind und was die auslösen
ja ich denke schon das sind Streifen die
sich am Himmel bilden die meisten Leute
denken das sind normale Kondensstreifen
sind verschiedene Giftstoffe drin soweit
ich weiß die atmen Sie ein ihr
Kameramann
wir alle ich auch
tatsächlich fällt ja auf dass heute der
Himmel komplett dicht ist ne weiß ne
sind das sind das die Chemtrails wird
gerade die ganze Zeit das sieht man doch
das leuchtet dann so schillern in allen
Farben das Aluminium
ich glaube ja die Lüge fängt viel früher
an
ich glaube der Flugzeug kann überhaupt
nicht fliegen sind nämlich viel zu
schwer das liegt an der Luft wenn die
unten sind geht es noch weil die Luft
drückt von unten gegen hoch
sobald man sagt diesen oben ja ab einer
gewissen da braucht man diese Chemtrails
auch als Kissen damit diese Flugzeuge
ach so weil sonst könnten die gar nicht
fliegen natürlich mit der Lügenpresse
keine Interview mit der Lügenpresse kein
Interview
hügen Presse Lügenpresse Lügenpresse
Rügen Fresse Lügenpresse
wer steuert das denn USA
US-Militär die wollen uns als
Bevölkerung reduzieren die sitzen da
oben und die sagen sich es gibt zu viele
Menschen vor allem in Europa wenn Sie
die gesamte Menschheit auf dem
australischen Kontinent unterbringen
dann ist das etwa so dicht bevölkert wie
München und ich war in München und bin
an keinen angestoßen kann also nicht zu
eng sein dann ist der Rest des
planetenfrei für Landwirtschaft oder
sonstiges also alle nach Australien es
ist nur ein eine Relation um mal zu
gucken ob er zu vielen Menschen auf
diesen Planeten haben mit
Eigentumswohnung gekauft was
interessiert mich nicht sie können aber
ruhig ihre Meinung sagen bezahlt ihr
seid noch bezahlt ihr werdet nie den
Menschenrechten entsprechend weil die
Deutschen mit dem Personalausweis nach
Hitler rumrennen und deswegen könnt ihr
die Menschenrechte brechen und ihr könnt
ihr Trost aber Kohle kassieren und das
Wort mehr will ich nicht schämen aber
ich musste auch Geld verdienen was also
wenn ich nicht bezahlt werde kann auch
nicht mehr blühen und mit Auslassung von
Wahrheiten der Wahrheit verdiene ich
kein Geld
[Musik]
gibt seit den 70er Jahren dann hat Rudi
Carrell den Protest Song gesungen wann
wird's mal wieder richtig Sommer muss
der deswegen sterben
er ist Quatsch kann ja sein das werde
lächerlich ist genauso wie Michael
Jackson und so die Interesse war zwar da
sondern Michael Jackson loszuwerden aber
zu auch wegen Chemtrails oder was nein
na weil der hat die auch die totale
Aufklärung gemacht in der Popmusik
dieses Jahr die Popmusik ist doch total
untereinander ich weiß ja auch ne also
lady Gaga ist die Schirmherrin von
dieser ganze Illuminaten Mucke
Vampirismus Porno blablabla Chemtrails
sind ja gegen die Klimakatastrophe das
heißt ja sie demonstrieren im Prinzip
für die Klimakatastrophe es gibt keine
Klima Katastrophe ach so ach das ja
interessant
ja aber was wie es gibt die nicht doch
wie was was gibt die nicht ich bin ja
kein Wissenschaftler und sie warum sind
Sie heute hier ich bin hier um dich zu
beobachten ach so warum weil ich auf
dich aufpassen soll dass du kein Quatsch
machst hier okay Fragen stellst und die
Leute nicht verarscht deswegen bin ich
hier
machte dich einfach nur
ey dann bleiben wir in Kontakt nee ich
beobachte dich
[Musik]
Honecker wäre stolz auf diesen Mann ist
doch schön wenn die Menschen Hobbys
haben manche beobachten Vögel manche die
Lügenpresse jetzt aber genug von
Verschwörungstheoretikern lass uns zum
Abschluss lieber darüber reden wie ich
einmal unser
staatsoberhauptinterviewt habe
du hast Frank Walter Steinmeier
getroffen
von der SPD ich meine unser richtiges
Staatsoberhaupt
wie jetzt Angela Merkel angela Merkel
ist ja nur ein kleines Rädchen im
Getriebe letzte Wort hat natürlich unser
Reichskanzler Norbert schittke in der
Politik und in dieser Sendung euer
Hoheit
bitte schön
[Musik]
sie mit Frau Merkel und in einem
Vier-Augen-Gespräch zusammen würde
absolut nichts bringen absolut nicht
weil sie alle Rechte in der Hand hat sie
ist die oberste Güter die wir sind alle
diesbezüglich gesteuert sie hat
Narrenfreiheit absolut und die nimmt
mich doch überhaupt nicht verfolgt
[Musik]
hatte Glück beim Militär aber ohne
Schießgewehr Frau Merkel ist kein Doktor
sie ist gar nicht sie ist nur von der
Stasi ausgebildet wie man Leute quält
wie man Kinder entführt wie man Leute
tötet und und
Angela Merkel ja und Kohl was hatten die
für ein Verhältnisse Helmut Kohl ist ein
Jude der jüdischen Familie hätte ich
Mädel kennengelernt Kinder gemacht eins
davon ist die Merkel wie in allen reden
sagt mein Mädels die Frau Merkel das ist
ja ein Knüller mit welchen Ländern
befinden wir uns den aktuell im
Kriegszustand mit 64 Stück bitte mit 64
stiften die Amerikaner alle gesammelt
haben und wenn ihr alle Leute hier im
Urlaub fahrt und so weiter landen wir
garantiert in einem Land das durch die
Amerikaner verführt mit uns im in der
feinstaatenklausel stehen und die
feinstaatenklausel steht nach wie vor
hoch das heißt also sie fahren in Feinde
stand immer Urlaub zu machen ich fahre
nach Spanien sind im peinlich Land ich
fahre nach Italien sind ja auch
wahrscheinlich
64 Länder ja wo soll ich da hinfahren
hier zu Hause bleiben arbeiten
[Musik]
die alte barana vom Sternbild alte Baran
die waren hier als Diplomaten wer sind
die sogenannten Alterbach
mal in Himmel gucken oder in Internet
ist einfach ein anderer Stern und die
beobachten die Erde seit langem und die
alte barane haben also die eigene
unterschiedlich mit dem stärksten und
besten ausgebildeten
führungsland hier auf der Erde immer
zusammen tun wollen zufälligerweise mit
Adolf Hitler damals haben dann auch dann
hier die Flugscheiben gebaut und sind
auch mit den
nach alte Bahn geflogen das ist
tatsächlich das Teil wasch mit auf der
Flugscheibe an der Außenhaut angebracht
war war auf alte Bahn und zurückgekehrt
da unten da saßen jetzt alte waraner
drin
der hat uns in dem Zweiten Weltkrieg
weniger genutzt die Italiener oder die
alte barana das haben die Italiener die
alte baraner sind
von einem anderen Planeten und die waren
hier ganz normal mit einem
Diplomatenpass ausgesetzt
haben die ein Herz eine Lunge sie können
sich mit den ganz normalen Kaffee
treffen und zusammen schöne stechen
Kaffee und Stück Kuchen essen waren sie
mit einem alten banana schon mal auf der
Erde Kaffee trinken ja
selbstverständlich
[Applaus]
die Vision ja das ist mehrere Eingänge
gibt zum Mittelpunkt der Ehre und das
statt mehrere Völker gibt die dort leben
das werden Sie wahrscheinlich auch
wissen und unter anderem ist deswegen ja
auch der Dalai Lama ein Freund von Adolf
Hitler gewesen weil Adolf dafür sehr
viel investiert hatte und tatsächlich
vom Himalaya gehen regelrechte Gänge und
Treppen runter das weiß ich wohin ich
war da auch noch nicht
wenn ich sie fragen darf was ist so
etwas wert außerdem ideellen Wert
natürlich was ist ihr Leben wird reicht
soll ich da antworten ich bin doch kein
Fantast natürlich
da sein durfte damit gebe ich zurück
nach Deutschland
[Musik]
und noch eine Anweisung von ganz oben
aus dem Staatsfunk Elfenbeinturm ihr
sollt jetzt alle den YouTube-Kanal der
heute-
ach so danke und das geilste die neue
best of Folge ist sogar schon in der ZDF
Mediathek und zwar hier da
man ich wollte doch jetzt selber mal
suchen jetzt weiß ich gehe wo geht's
hier raus da